don't get stuck in a cycle break the
cycle what are the emotions you feel
when it comes to money fear shame and
guilt I've done something wrong guilt
that I don't have my act together it
seems like everyone else is Ken and
Barbie everyone else has their act
together but not at our house we
surveyed a bunch of you tens of
thousands of people we talk to 80% of
those surveyed said they were in the
messy middle or in crisis can't seem to
get traction just as a chaos we're on
the edge of the cliff or the car is
going over the cliff I mean we're in
facing foreclosure or reposition or
might any moment that means folks are
stuck Cycles repeat and reinforce and
the only way to break a cycle is to
start a new cycle to start a new
Behavior to replace the old Behavior